okay so the mcu is filled with hundreds
and hundreds of amazing moments it's a
franchise that truly deserves its
legendary status and it's difficult to
not marvel at all its achievements which
as of now are unmatched by any other
studio picking the moment that embodies
all that is very difficult but there's
one scene that forever stands out in my
mind as being absolutely perfect it's a
scene that had audiences doing this
[Applause]
but why does it work so well and why is
it that the moment somehow gets better
after multiple watches well throughout
this video we're going to be breaking
down exactly what makes this scene what
it is as well as the storytelling behind
it that just makes everything about this
a complete knockout now if you love the
scene i'd massively appreciate the
thumbs up button and don't forget to
subscribe for videos like this each and
every week in which we examine the best
parts of cinema and discuss what makes
them great if you're new here then this
is the heavy spoiler show i'm your host
paul aka your friendly neighborhood
spoiler man now let's get into why this
scene in avengers infinity war is
perfect
okay so thought arriving on wakanda to
save the heroes in their most desperate
moment works on a number of levels not
only because of what happens after it
but also because of what comes before
throughout the mcu thor was always a
hero to me that was way too
overconfident in his abilities in fact
when we first meet him this great
character flaw is the thing that gets
him cast out of asgore and his first
solo movie is about him proving that
he's worthy of being the king that his
father wants him to be now for as
self-assured as he is when we look back
at the series thor is also the person
that has lost the most before the events
of him journeying to wakanda not only
did he lose his mother he also lost his
father sister brother
well-adopted brother home best friend
and half of all his people after thanos
attack on his ship he's easily been on
the most devastating arc in the entire
series but this loss also gave him a
false perception of himself and what
fate had decreed for him in infinity war
he even says that he's only alive
because fate wills it so because he'd
lost so much and yet always come out on
top he himself believes that the odds
will always be in his favor and even
when he looks like he's done that he'll
bounce back this again plays into his
character flaw and self-belief which
we'll touch upon more later on in the
video now this line about fate massively
plays into how well the movie is crafted
and it lulls us into a false sense of
security so that the rug is pulled from
under our feet come the final act what
infinity war does so well and why the
snap feels so devastating is because the
movie tricks us into believing that the
avengers will win there's the
aforementioned fate bid but beyond that
there's several lines of dialogue and
motifs that lead us down the path to
thinking that thanos is done for after
surviving the onslaught thor sets out on
a quest to get stormbreaker a mythical
weapon of great power if we look at
cinematic conventions most movies in the
genre involve the hero going on a quest
to get a macguffin that will help them
to defeat the villain we're even told
that stormbreaker is a weapon which is
the thanos killing kind so thor going
through the journey that he does in
which he gains it at the end makes us
believe that he now has the power to
stop the mad titan the movie also uses
our expectations to make us think that
we know exactly the way that it's gonna
go in the franchise we've already seen
the avengers team up and defeat several
villains and thought arriving on wakanda
perfectly mimics the scene from their
first team-up movie when we play them
side by side we can see that the same
stances where the camera is used to
portray movement and the music are all
deliberately chosen to lure us into a
false sense of security it's masterful
filmmaking and makes the twist a
complete gut punch as due to all this
buildup we were sure that the good guys
were gonna win now why this scene also
works incredibly well is the immediate
build up to it our heroes on earth are
facing insurmountable odds as the forces
of thanos swamp them and it seems like
all is lost that is until the bifrost
shoots down with a bass sound that will
crack your subwoofer and stormbreaker
flies out of it within seconds thanos's
soldiers are completely decimated and
when it returns to thor's hand we see
the hero once more standing there
triumphant throughout the film thor has
painted a sorry picture of himself and
he's very much been a character that's
defeated and down on his luck however
his return here shows the character that
we know and love is back and he's ready
to take on thanos
[Music]
now why this works so well is because
throughout the film thor has been going
about things away from thanos rather
than traveling to nowhere to take him on
with the guardians he went into vidalia
in order to get stormbreaker i wouldn't
necessarily call it cowardly but he
wasn't really rushing to battle and up
until this point in the film the
character hasn't had the action scenes
that the others have he's been a shadow
of his former self almost wallowing in
self-pity and on the verge of bully
maguire asking him if he's gonna cry now
however here he's a complete opposite to
that and rather than skirting around the
edges he's running head first to his
opponents and completely wiping them out
in the process it's difficult to not get
swept up in this moment and because of
this scene you can't wait until thor
finally beats the villain and writes the
wrongs of all that has been done to him
there's no way he can lose
however calling back to our earlier
point it's thor's great character flaw
that is the reason why he does and why
he also dooms the universe in the finale
after thanos has collected all of the
infinity stones we see stormbreaker
rushing towards the villain but rather
than hitting him in the head it goes
into his chest thor has the opportunity
to kill him but rather than delivering a
killing stroke he prefers to gloat and
rub it in thanos's face that he's won
this overconfidence and need to boast is
the thing that has always been his
downfall and just as we've seen before
he fails because of it a moment that
should be his greatest triumph is now
his greatest failing and we watch an
endgame as he has to wrestle with the
fact that him taking this action is what
destroys not only half of all life in
the universe but also his belief in
himself
this is exactly why his arrival on
wakanda is so perfect beyond just being
a cool entrance that saves his friends
from death it has a number of layers to
it that perfectly show the good points
and bad points of his character though
riding confidently into battle believing
that fate wills him to win is precisely
why he ends up losing in the end and the
scene is masterful in its storytelling
not only does it perfectly recapture the
elements from earlier in the franchise
but it also uses them to make us believe
that the film is going to go a certain
way us seeing a self-assured confident
thought here makes our confidence rise
as well as we as an audience believe
that the heroes are gonna come through
in the end however this high is also
what makes the lows of the snap even
more devastating and the movie perfectly
uses this moment to prop up its heroes
so that they can fall even more those
standing here confidently is a complete
juxtaposition to how we catch the heroes
in the final scene and whereas here he
props himself up tall and proud caps
slumps on the ground over the vision's
corpse knowing that all is lost the
dynamics of the film are complete
opposite ends to each other and the snap
only feels so crushing to us because it
follows on from the scene in which we
were celebrating the return of one of
the best avengers he watches the hero
goes on an arc of being defeated to
rising up only to be crushed again by
the final twist and that is why this
moment is so perfect it catches the
character as he believes he's bounced
back which makes it all the more
devastating when we see him lose the
music is perfect the timing of the scene
is perfect and the fact that it bases
itself heavily on both the good and bad
in thor's character is what makes it
astounding it also brings in several
elements from earlier in the franchise
and just gets you so hyped for the
climax of the film that it's difficult
to not get swept up in it every time you
watch it though arriving on wakunder is
one of my favorite scenes in any comic
book film i think it's going to be a
while before the mcu tops this in my
eyes i'm still blown away by it today
and this is why i believe that it's the
perfect scene
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the moment so make sure you
comment below and let me know we're
running a competition right now and
giving away three mcu box sets on the
30th of august and all you have to do to
be on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the scene we
picked the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now so if that's
you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers you want emails to watch
then make sure you check out our
breakdown of why the flash scene in
justice league is perfect in our opinion
we go over all the highs and lows of it
and i think you'll appreciate it a lot
more after you watch the video if not
then thank you for sitting until the end
of this one i've been paul you've been
the best i'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]